hey there friends you want to see
something cool come over
here so this right here this is a
painting by a baltimore-based artist by
the name of so s o g it came to be on my
wall after seeing it at an art fair in
Baltimore I want to say seven or eight
years ago and it is probably my favorite
piece that I have on my walls at home
right now this is a performance by Cyrus
Spencer and comfort as part of season 9
of So You Think You Can Dance and it is
my favorite dance performance of all
time not only does it tell a really fun
story but there's an entire middle
section of it involving a tutting
sequence that blows my mind still to
this day this is a Tyrannosaurus Rex
model I believe from Safari Limited I
got it at Awesome Con in Washington DC a
few years ago and it brings me joy every
time I look at it this was from a brief
period where we thought there was a good
likelihood that Tyrannosaurus Rex as an
adult had feathers cuz we're almost
positive they had them when they were
juveniles uh but since then there have
been studies to refute this but
nonetheless this was such a cool find
and every time I see it over on my
bookshelf it makes me smile all right so
why am I talking about all these
different things well it's because they
all have one thing in common namely that
I think that they are beautiful and I'd
like to talk to you today a little bit
about beauty why I think it's important
and why it motivates me as an artist and
I hope that it'll motivate you
too Drex here from Drex Factor Poise
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I want to talk
with you a little bit about beauty and
how it intersects with the flow Arts but
before we dive in I just want to give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrro Tera light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- business
friend of the channel Becca beonin thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission now bear
with me here because this is going to
get a little heavy at times but
basically when I was seven or eight
years old I think I had my first
existential crisis when I came to
understand what the ultimate fate of the
universe is and that is that everything
that we know will one day be gone and I
don't mean in the sense of you know in
another 30 years your house is going to
get torn down and another one's going to
be built in its place or even that
civilizations come and go or even that
some someday the Sun is going to explode
and eat up the Earth no I'm talking
trillions upon trillions more years in
the future because eventually all the
mass in the universe is going to be
concentrated in black holes and we're
going to have an entire universe full of
black hole galaxies and then beyond that
all those black holes are going to
eventually evaporate and we're going to
be left with a completely empty Universe
in which there are light years between
fundamental particles and there is never
any hope that any of those particles
will ever interact again the universe
will be cold empty and lifeless for all
eternity so as you might imagine as a
child this freaked the living out
of me this began what would turn out to
be an entire lifetimes worth of insomnia
in which I pondered gigantic questions
and kept myself awake all night as a
result of it this is my favorite book of
all time the yish policeman's Union by
Michael chabon it is basically a hard
boil detective story that is set in an
alternate version of Alaska and it has
some of the most beautiful and
heartbreaking Pros I have ever read in
my life in fact if I could have the
ability to erase one book that I have
read in my life and be able to go back
and have the experience of reading it
for the first time all over again this
without question is the book that I
would do it for this right here is a
recipe for chicken tikka masala that I
came across Ross during the pandemic now
this recipe is a commitment it only says
that it takes about 45 minutes to cook
on it but really it's closer to like 2
or 3 hours so I really have to clear out
a block of time in order to make it
happen but my goodness it is so worth it
this is probably my favorite thing to
cook for myself and it has been agreed
by many many friends that this is
without Pier the single tastiest thing
that I can cook up right now so this is
Sandalwood incense perhaps a little bit
basic but what I really like about this
is both how simultaneously musky it is
while also very calming and pleasant I
usually burn incense kind of frequently
in order to re-regulate myself and get
to a point where I'm more relaxed and
Sandalwood is definitely my favorite
scent for this so I like many people
staring down the barrel of the Void
started asking myself big questions if
the ultimate fate of everything was just
to be completely erased for all eternity
then what was the point point of all the
things that we created what was the
point of existence what was the point of
anything that I would do in the course
of my life I didn't have an answer then
but I think I have a better answer now
so there's a lot of reasons why this
freaks me out but one of the biggest
ones is just that I kind of love the
world around us I think that there's a
lot of things in it that are beautiful
and the idea of losing all those things
of they're not even being a trace of
them left is something that makes me
really sad so I had a day earlier this
week when I was just not okay and I set
aside a block of time for myself during
the course of the day to emotionally
re-regulate myself what that consisted
of was that I lit up some incense I
played some of my favorite music and I
reread my favorite issue of one of my
favorite graphic novels of all time and
you know what it just brought me this
feeling of peace and joy that I was able
to take with me through the rest of the
day by interacting with these beautiful
things it improved the quality of my day
and by extension kind of the quality of
that little piece of my life this is my
favorite album of all time Who's Next by
The Who the first track on it Baba
O'Reilly is my favorite song of all time
I can remember falling in love with this
record when I was very little maybe five
or 6 years old and I remember just
pushing all of the buttons on my parents
stereo trying to figure out the specific
combination that I needed in order to
make this record come out of the
speakers and it features what I think is
one of the all-time greatest choruses in
all of Rock and Roll
[Music]
History this is Hanabi my favorite card
game I own three copies of it and I
bring around a copy with me wherever I
go so I can introduce strangers to it
the central idea behind this game is
that everybody receives a hand of cards
and everybody can see the hands of
everybody else at the table except their
own you want to try and distribute hints
to everybody so that you lay down the
cards in a particular order it's an easy
game to describe but it's incredibly
challenging to actually play I have
gotten a perfect score on this game only
five times in the past 10 years this
right here is a shoulder bag that I have
owned for the better part of 15 years I
acquired it at a music festival called
Floy Fest that happens out in Virginia
and I deeply regret that I do not
remember the name of the artist that I
purchased it from because this is one of
my absolute most favorite
possessions and as you can see it's
getting a little threadbear and I have a
feeling that probably within the coming
year there will be a catastrophic
failure with some part of this bag and I
will be so so sad to have to let it go
so if any of you out there are watching
and you've been to floydfest and you've
purchased one of these bags let me know
who this person was because I would
really love to get another one I really
don't think that we realize very often
just how lucky we are it's not just that
we have this universe where there's this
point in between it being a hot dense
soup of matter to being an endless void
of nothing where it was possible for
life like us to evolve to say nothing of
the fact that we happened to come about
on a planet that was in the habitable
zone of a particular star and that all
of the necessary quirks of evolution
that had to happen for us to be here did
happen heck the vast majority of human
beings that have ever existed are
already dead most of them died in
childhood we exist in a very very very
narrow range of possibilities we're
extraordinarily lucky to be here I know
that it's easy to take that for granted
when there's what 7 or eight billion of
us on this planet in counting how can
all of us be lucky when there's so many
of us here and well the fact that there
are so many of us here is a testament to
just how much work has happened over the
course of the entirety of Humanity's
history to try and figure out how to
give as many of us as possible that
opportunity to experience creation so
this right here is my base it is a
sterling Stingray which means that it's
the budget brand version of a music man
Stingray it's got Active Electronics and
overall the feel is pretty similar to
what you'd find with uh a p base up to
that point I've been using mainly
hand-me-downs and I wanted something
that actually felt like me so I went to
the local music store and I got a couple
friends to help me out with an
experiment namely they took each and
every base in that music store I sat
down in a chair I closed my eyes and one
by one they put each base in my lap and
had me play it I had nothing to go by
except for how the bases felt and how
they sounded and after trying each and
every base in the store this was the
clear
winner it's also gorgeous I have to say
I look at this hanging on my wall every
once in a while and I'm just struck by
the beauty of this after all that work I
can honestly say that my Bas sounds like
me and me
alone this right here is a figurine that
a good friend of mine gave me uh not
that terribly long ago actually uh it is
a depiction of a Sami person wearing
gaki the reason that she gave this to me
is that uh my family's ancestors were
Sami before they came over from Finland
they assimilated a few Generations ago
so unfortunately
um I don't know what our family GOI
would have looked like I don't speak the
language and near as I can tell aside
from one stew recipe that's been in the
family for a while there's nothing else
that remains of the original SII culture
that we came from which is really sad
and it's been a priority for me the past
few years to learn more about that
culture to start learning the language
and to hopefully one day feel as though
I can reclaim part of what was lost to
us and and even though I've already done
some research on this and I know that uh
the colors and the patterns aren't quite
right it's it's an admirable attempt but
nonetheless seeing this little figure uh
up on my bookshelf is a reminder to me
and kind of a hope that one day I will
have more of myami Heritage than just a
figurine sitting on my shelf these are
fabric poy from sock poy as you might
imagine I used a lot and I do mean a lot
of sets of poy over the course of my
career and there's a reason that you
always see these popping up these are
what I spend most often these are what I
feel most comfortable with right now I
feel like they are the perfect
compliment for where I am in my flow
Journey right now they show up
beautifully on camera the weight and
handling of them is perfect for my style
of dance and honestly they're really
portable and they just feel right to me
I absolutely adore these so whenever I
see all these beautiful things around me
from paintings to music graphic novels
dance you name it there's a little part
of me that's a little sad because I know
that one day it's all going to disappear
and the last person that even remembered
it existed will be gone from the
universe any Trace that it ever existed
will be gone as well but at the same
time I feel an enormous amount of
gratitude that I got to experience those
things
there's so many objects events people
performances Etc that have crossed my
path over the time that I've been here
that I feel an enormous amount of
gratitude for being able to experience
all these little things have improved my
time here and in all honesty I think
that this is part of what makes these
things beautiful the fact that they are
temporary the fact that they're not
going to last the fact that we are
taking this narrow window of time that
we have access to and we're using that
time to reorder creation
into things that are beautiful to us and
that improve our experiences of being
here in a lot of ways I think that
creating those beautiful things in and
of itself is an act of defiance against
the void I know that it surely is for me
sure I know that eventually the void is
going to win and that all of it is going
to be gone but in the meantime I can get
so much joy from being able to put
things into creation and appreciating
the things that still exist as a part of
it we all make choices about the things
that we surround ourselves with we think
about what enriches our environment what
enriches our experience of being here
and we collect those things around us
that improve those experiences and for
some of us that is artists and creatives
well it becomes our job to put new
beautiful things into the world this is
volume seven of the Sandman probably my
favorite comic series of all time and
ironically enough this was actually the
first collection from the series that I
ever read this story features by far
what I think is my favorite thing I have
ever read from Neil Gaiman wherein
there's a man who is over 10,000 years
old and he dies unexpectedly when a
building falls over on him when death
comes to pick him up and move him on to
what comes next he insists I did pretty
good here didn't I I got in 10,000 years
to which death replies you got what
anybody got you got a lifetime no more
no less so the
are a set of jeans that I found at Ross
while I was shopping for something
completely different and I think they're
the only pair of pants that I have ever
owned that when I wear them I feel
attractive this is a rehearsal video
from New York based dancer and
choreographer Melissa becraft Melissa
becraft has actually uploaded a lot of
videos that I really like over the years
but what makes this one stick out to me
is just the incredible musicality of it
when I think of musicality and
especially with my own po dance
this right here is the example that I'm
pulling from in my mind this is one of
the primary motivators for doing all the
PO Dance videos that I've been uploading
in the past 2 years it's all about
creating things that I think are
beautiful that when I look at them I
have an appreciation and say wow I can't
believe that I did that one of the
things I love most about those po Dance
videos is going back and watching them
on an idle Saturday afternoon getting to
experience them again watching them and
being like wow I'm really glad that this
exists in the world and I have to say I
feel really lucky to live in a time
where we have the technology to be able
to go back and re-watch dance any all
time we want most of human history has
not been like that and my goodness is it
a part of this period in history that I
really appreciate last year I
choreographed my first full po piece to
an entire song in years and going back
and watching it even to this day it
makes me so proud to have done that
there's a PO dance video that I shot
just a month ago that is choreographed
so tightly to the music that I can tell
exactly what's going on in the music
even without the audio it's the first
time I've ever seen that happen in my
own po dance and I just continue to be
overwhelmed with pride over that so here
is my challenge to you make beautiful
things make things that help you
appreciate your time here and make
things that help other people appreciate
their time here too it's beautiful
because it is so fleeting and that's why
it's worth doing and as for me right now
I'm in the midst of creating a new
beautiful thing I found a new song that
I'm choreographing too and so far I'm
pretty happy with how the results are
turning out so I am going to set up the
camera right quick to record all
that and as I'm doing that I'm going to
go ahead and do my usual shout out to my
patreon supporters for supporting this
video and all all the videos on my
channel going to have a little popup
that's appearing on screen right now as
I'm talking about this I'm going to show
you what I'm working on and I hope you
appreciate it if you got anything out of
this video I hope you'll consider
signing up to support me making
additional videos like this and putting
more beautiful things into the world you
can do that by heading on over to
patreon and signing up at
patreon.com slir Factor
Po in the
meantime here's what I got
cooking I hope you like
it something's got a hold of me lately
no I don't know myself in
know feels like the wall are all closing
in and the devil's knocking at my door
wo out of my mind how many times did I
tell you I'm no good at being
alone yeah it's taking a toll on me
trying my best to keep from tapping the
skin off my bones don't you
know I lose one tell
H when you're not next to
me I'm falling apart right in front of
you can't you
see I
L when you're not next to me